[Musique]
c'est à vous de jouer
l'échec d'abou du et alors vous laisse
où tout a changé quand même pas encore
d'idée le petit enfant
ça nous permet au moteur s'éteint
j
leur revient
échec et mat oui c'est vrai que rien
faire
demain dans ma famille un grand joueur
et beau perdant aldo vie scotty ébéniste
de son état a toujours vécu rue d'aligre
à deux pas de la gare de lyon
lui et ses amis auvergnats ou
méridionaux ont adopté ce quartier comme
si à peine débarqué il avait fait 100
200 m avaient posé leurs valises et
s'était installé comme si le train que
l'on entend parfois tout proche le
rapportait encore les échos de la terre
natale
[Musique]
à l'heure où paris s'éveille pierrot
patron du bistrot de la place d'à lire
et auvergnats de pure souche ouvre ses
grilles sur un désert apparent en fait
ses premiers clients commencent leur
journée dans la nuit ce sont les
maraîchers premier levé sur la place
pierrou à réinventer pour ses voisins
le très ancien métier de crieur de nuit
jack des lecteurs m'ont dit les pêches
mois
sur le zinc premier café premier contact
et la complicité de ceux qui la fortune
est promise
les lève tôt vit dans le quartier depuis
combien de temps prend du temps mais moi
je sais pas si je sais je suis né mais
mon père il n'y aura bientôt de 50 ans
qui était à pied se trouve à proximité
de la gare de lyon et 6 ans c'est un
quartier typiquement algérien ont
perturbé relief ne vais rien de bien
neuf est rien mais dans le quartier y en
avait beaucoup alors à l'époque où ils
sont arrivés
et puis alors c'est un quartier où on
s'habitue très facilement pu compenser
c'est un village plutôt aussi sous le
nom de se caler tout le monde m'appelle
pierrot tu penses je connais tout le
monde toutes les histoires du coin et
puis alors on trouve quand même beaucoup
d'entre elles dont le trouve je ne sais
pas tout le monde se penche un peu sur
le problème des autres c'est vraiment le
village dans paris ça n'a rien à voir
avec d'autres quartiers
c'est vraiment quelque chose de
formidable parce qu'on s'y attache
comment sa tâche et son clocher
vous êtes d'origine italienne à l'eau
orie
et nous sommes arrivés en france en 1907
à dire c'est ma mère et sept expatriés à
première parce que du fait de la marche
sur rome et donc comme elle était
militante à l'époque socialiste elle a
dû quitter le pays dès quitter turin en
8es elle est donc elle est venue
chercher un an après en passant la
frontière une nouvelle fois avec un faux
passeport et je suis content que nous
sommes l'arrivée c'est à dire mon père
un suivi après et nous sommes arrivés à
place d'aligre 1923 où il a trouvé du
travail dans le garage de labour bord
qui n'existe plus maintenant puisque
c'étaient ses démolir l'immeuble neuf et
j'ai toujours vécu là et mon père lui
n'était pas ce n'était pas un homme
militant a faim il s'occupait pas de
politique des choses comme ça et
d'ailleurs c'était tout à fait normal
parce que en plus qui vivaient déjà dans
un pays qui était le sien alors c'est
lui qui m'a conseillé de faire
naturaliser français dont on finance
parti à la guerre pour avoir le droit à
la parole comme maintenant voilà c'est
simple
et comme quand la place d'aligre enfin
le cas de la place davilla été démoli il
a donc fallu que tous les tous les amis
et les camarades du cancer et en quatre
pour me trouver un petite pièce pour ne
pas quitter cette place que vous
connaissez bien que vous avez
certainement aussi voilà c'est simple
mais l'idée de quitter ce quartier ça a
été oui c'est pas possible pas possible
ou retrouvera-t-on chaque matin ses amis
dans la chaleur de ce bistrot vieillot
où les retrouverez ton les artisans les
vendeurs de bric-à-brac les marchands de
fleurs les maraîchers les forts en
gueule et l'ecopad à paris-match gaza
seraient tous les matins je m'amuse
martel et notamment des gitans du mois
de janvier aux vans
[Musique]
regardez bien
de plus en plus un interphone et une
rangée de casiers la remplace alors on
ne distribuera plus à chaque un courrier
et petits petons
ils ont mangé deux croissants fait par
papa et de bol de chocolat et comme il
est 8 heures deux chacun sous sa capuche
répète deux fois 2 en allant à l'école à
deux pas ici chacun s'est installé à son
idée il a apporté son toit sa fenêtre
cela donne ce millefeuille tarabiscoté
cet entassement de petits immeubles de
guingois chez les élus locaux
on rêve plutôt d'une belle ordonnance de
pierres de taille et de beto un
architecte gérard thurnauer chargé de la
construction d'une ville nouvelle le
vaudreuil s'est jointe à nous c'est la
dimension humaine de cette rue qui me
fascine il s'en souviendra
pour ces projets d'urbanisme je me
semble que dans un quartier comme celui
là
la qualité des rapports humains vient
essentiellement d'une certaine
homogénéité du quartier cette cohérence
d'un quartier vient très souvent du fait
que dans ce même quartier
les gens peuvent à la fois bien sûr y
habiter ils trouvaient des fonctions
importantes comme la fonction
commerciale de cette rue est
particulièrement impressionnant sur ce
plan là et puis en plus ils trouvaient
aussi des lieux de travail des lieux de
travail
tout près de chez soi qui n'en rêve pas
ici il existe même s'ils sont pour le
moins inattendu
c'est le quartier du bois et du meuble
le faubourg saint-antoine n'est pas le
bon
d'immenses progrès je m'en sors jour
nous précèdent les anguilles je sais pas
je sais pas c'est mana des américains
jaloux je souffre je reviens alors c'est
bon ça mais pas avec à bichkek barrage
face à l'eire
alors tu te reposer un peu tôt oui ça
[Musique]
ça va surgir comme on a plus de fric qui
donne moi oui en bout de compte ça va
aller je suis note du pays ce matin
rien n'a disparu fondu complètement le
marché c'est le plaisir du temps
dépensée gaspillé peut-être mais
toujours justifiées on flâne sans en
avoir l'air on flaire opale on soupèse
on discute de la marchandise et d'autres
choses de rien et de tous et puis on
compte et on rêve un plaisir de tous les
sens et de la tête une fête des
rencontres un spectacle où chacun peut
avoir sa part
bientôt des paras mental oui c'est le
russe alors lucide ans
aujourd'hui c'est tout je lis ça c'est
la fête à guy doré avant l'étude de côté
ça fait le guillou lori nichol ans à
l'école vers une mise alors avec un beau
temps comme ça on traduit
regarde
c'est alors j'ai aperçu madame boutin je
voulais lui dire bonjour la disparue qui
va pas non je sais pas comment ça se
fait
alors mon truc achètent toujours avoir
un bébé noir bien ici on a tellement
d'amis dans ce quartier ah oui vieillit
pas quoi parce qu'on ne peut même pas
aller chez tout le monde penserait trop
connu c'est à l'ennui est ce que c'est
important la rue spectacle très
important son but il surtout quand on
imagine en plus le côté très quotidien
de l'existence de la plupart de ces gens
visiblement un jour comme celui là le
marché constitue pas seulement un
endroit où on peut venir faire ses
courses mais certainement un endroit où
cette fonction d'achat se mêle à une un
plaisir notion de loisir et on sent très
bien qu'il ya ya ce côté
assez latin et
des personnes qui viennent là pour
déambuler choisir regarder voir les
autres se faire voir aussi ce qui fait
partie de cette vie
particulièrement intense qu'on voit là
jusque dans les villes nouvelles dans
les grandes cités ce qu'il est possible
d'envisager là
et des marchés comme ça qu'il y aurait
deux fois par semaine on risque de voir
apparaître les ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les grandes surfaces c'est à
dire un nouveau mode de commerce et qui
risquent de de pomper dans le dans la
ville elle-même tout
ces fonctions commerciales ou ses
activités commerciales soient légères
soi même qui peuvent se passer dans les
boutiques traditionnelles et là ya
visiblement un problème qui dépasse le
simple problème de l'organisation de
l'espace puisque c'est essentiellement
un problème économique et je pense que
l'une des choses sur lesquelles on
devrait être particulièrement prudent
c'est précisément de pouvoir laisser ce
type d'activités économiques se
développer dans les nouveaux ensembles
parce que il constitue quelque chose de
tout à fait tir en place à bhl au niveau
précisément de ce spectacle et de la
qualité de vie sociale qui devrait
pouvoir s'établir dans ses nouveaux
quartiers
est ce que l'arrivée d'un hip hop comme
celui ci ne porte pas en soi la
condamnation déjà je crois
qu'effectivement la vie d'un quartier
comme celui là est très très gravement
mise en péril
et ça me semble-t-il c'est grave sur le
fond ce n'est pas me semble-t-il un
problème de forme ce n'est pas un
immeuble en soi ou la transformation
d'un immeuble en soit seulement qui est
importante c'est vraisemblablement tout
tout ce qu'il va entraîner petit à petit
au niveau de la disparition des
catégories socio professionnelles qui
sont dans ce quartier qui est leur
quartier beaucoup de gens voient
seulement être obligé de partir les
activités dont nous avons parlé au
niveau de l'artisanat risque également
de partir on pourrait quand même
retrouver des formes nouvelles qui
permettent cette qualité de vie d'un
quartier mais vrai sa demande
des modes de rénovation urbaine qui
serait très différent de ceux pratiqués
aujourd'hui
mais ne vous y trompez pas tout n'est
pas défendable dans la rue pour le 12ème
arrondissement
50 % des immeubles ne disposent pas de
l'eau courante 40 % n'ont pas de w c
pour chaque appartement
54 % n'ont pas de chauffage central plus
de la moitié des appartements ne
comporte pas plus de trois ans
voilà et je vois des gens qui sont à
l'extérieur de paris et qu'ils ont été
compris et les qui sont soit je dirais
même qu'elle a qui sont à un jeune
villageois verviers et ils refont un
échange pour revenir dans le coin ça
c'est pas une c'est définitivement une
et par an toutes les semaines que nous
voyons des clients reviennent au marché
sur baigné dans cette ambiance de
quartier qui n'ont pas abandonné ce qui
arrive
cole au quartier moi je pense je crois
c'est par sa taille ça compte comme ça
je crois risquons aviaire bien ce matin
chez un client c'est pas vieux et ce
matin à 5h30
j'ai un client est arrivé avec sa femme
il vient de belgique
il vient à peu près tous les ans ils
étaient donc et bien tous les ans quand
tu viens à paris il revient place des
lions il doit revenir demain avant de
partir elle allait retrouver les amis
dessus des yeux copains c'est vraiment
le village passé oui c'est vraiment le
thé le vidal salué un peu moi elle
l'était certainement peut-être un peu un
côté bohème et si les puces des mêmes
les clochards qui sont assez sympa avec
nous afin qu'ils nous font dès qu'ils
nous rendent des petits services
c'est marrant ce qu'on aime c'est la vie
en commun avec son folklore ses rites et
ses coutumes
[Musique]
on regarde le concert hommage n'oblige
dans et nouvelles mines au système
rahmani un an violetten au bas du coteau
ça vaut bien mieux femme chérie et paris
harry est ce que vous avez l'impression
qu'on peut ranger cette rue et 6 7 8 ans
et la transplanter comme ça tel quel
dans une hd est ce que ça se passera
bien
la question qui se pose c'est comment
retrouver une organisation de l'espace
dans ces quartiers neufs qui permettent
précisément que des rapports sociaux
même si son de caractéristiques un peu
différente de celle que nous voyons ici
s'établissent cet avis et créer une
véritable vie collective et c'est un
problème
d'autant plus difficile que dans ces
quartiers nouveaux souvent les gens qui
sont chargés d'en assurer la conception
ont relativement peu d'éléments sur le
profil exact des futurs habitants
alors ils peuvent faire un certain
nombre d'hypothèses
quand ces quartiers sont réussis ou
deviennent réussi dans le temps parce
qu'on est souvent un peu impatient il
faut souvent trois quatre cinq ans avant
que commence à ce qui c'est tout un tas
de relations sociales s'y rend plus
l'espace qu'on a le prévu permet que ces
relations sociales s'établissent
que la nation celle là c'est barbara nom
n'est pas allé comme par la compote les
7,1 mais pas du coin qui nous vendent
ces des cds l'élastique c'est du pipeau
dessus non s'ils veulent acheter au
fassois des bons d'achat chez boulanger
[Musique]
est ce que pour vous la rue c'est une
c'est une école c'est une école de la
vie oui ça je crois que c'est une idée
très très très forte
c'est une idée très forte on le sent
très bien notamment au niveau des
enfants quand on peut leur donner des
cheminements où se situe
des activités où il peut voir des gens
les reconnaître quand ils passent par
exemple quand ils vont à l'école et sans
avoir les dangers de la circulation je
crois sont là que la rue est un est une
sorte de du livre que qu'on peut lire et
qu'on a du plaisir à lire et d'ailleurs
pas seulement pour les enfants
il ya continuellement le long de la rue
des éléments qui vous sollicitent le des
vitrines qu'on a envie de regarder un
certain nombre de gens qui passent
c'est un lieu de vie et je par ceux là
même c'est certainement une école
excellente
un de leurs souvenirs d'enfance sera cet
atelier déçu et images d'epinal d'une
ère artisanale révolue
[Applaudissements]
et quand ils seront adultes ils n'auront
plus besoin de clé fabriqués à tout vent
et a pleinement
il y aura des champs magnétiques et des
rayons laser y lire aussi des souvenirs
et des images peur tête
[Musique]
ils seront aussi à quoi ressemble une
rue un terrain de jeu un jeu de piste
une forêt un forum est peut-être leurs
meilleures salles de classe
[Musique]
j'ai mangé la dernière parce que tu
montes prêté deux chaises j'ai la
famille qu'il est là mais je suis à
cours atteint seulement pierrot et aldo
ne veulent pas vivre sans leurs rues et
leur place ici est leur vie ce qui nous
enseigne c'est ceci ne disons pas vive
le passé ne feuilleton pas tendrement
l'album d'un pari toujours vivant en
essayons plutôt de sauver les vertus de
la rue pour les villes de demain
[Musique]